hello everyone and yes as the title
suggests uh that is exactly what
happened uh imagine you're playing chess
in a bar and all of a sudden a world
champion walks in uh in this case that
being magnus cross and this is exactly
what happened i believe yesterday as uh
with something from the epfl chess club
uh sent me
an email uh and he sent me a
two reddit post with the recordings of
the games that they played uh magnus
played two games maybe he played more
but two of them were recorded and
well i decided to show at least one of
them if you guys will enjoy this one we
can show uh the other one as well uh so
they were playing in a university the
swiss institute of technology of
lausanne the epfl which is in
switzerland and uh well like i said
magnus just walks in the bar and uh here
we have a very nice game against video
master niels williams uh and it's uh
it's actually a wonderful game in the
very very struck
well a very instructive one uh so hope
you guys will enjoy this and uh how many
times were you playing chess in a bar
and you know
uh you know okay the world champion
didn't walk
through the front door but uh if you
played in a library or if they played in
a library they would never get a chance
to play the world champion so never
underestimate the power of playing chess
in a bar now that being said let's check
out this game
so williams
has the white pieces and he opens with
c4 he goes for the english opening we
have c6 by magnus knight to c3 d5 uh e3
and knight to f6 so these are the the
opening moves i don't know if this is
the exact order in which they were
played as there is a video of this game
so you can see i will uh only
show you a very very short clip so you
can see that the game actually is being
recorded from this position
there you have it so just to get into
the mood of of the game they're using a
smartphone as a chest clock and it's uh
it's either very quick blitz i imagine a
three plus sol or maybe even a two plus
so it could also very well be bullet one
plus or what i don't think it is i think
it's more uh a two plus or a three plus
oh so considered a little be on the
robot either from you know uh
blitz or or maybe a bullet-ish blitz so
let's now continue as i think this was
the the order in which the move was were
played but now we have the rest of the
move so knight to f3 we have g6 uh b3
preparing to fiance to the dark square
bishop and of course magnus puts his
bishop on this diagonal as well to
counter
williams dark square bishop so bishop to
b2 magnus castles with bishop to e2 and
bishop to g4
uh williams castles and now a6 so magnus
developed the light squad bishop and now
he has put all of his pawns on light
squares which means that once this
bishop is attacked he is going to trade
it for knight and he will have a dark
square bishop and all of his pawns on
light squares which is uh
very nice so h3 we have bishop captures
and f3 bishop captures and not knight b
to d7 continuing development and uh
white uh
just strikes in the center with the d4
and this is also very very good for for
white so here we have rook to e8 and now
comes a move that has never been played
before so the this position exists in a
database queen to c2 is a known move but
after e4 yeah it is as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game uh so
magnus captures on e4 we have knight
captures on e4 knight captures bishop
captures and now magnus strikes in the
center with e5 now like i said this is a
very very quick chess uh maybe
f5 first would have been a slight
improvement after the bishop moves then
we can push e5 and now white doesn't
really have all that much time to push
the pawn to d5 because e4 is also coming
so maybe it would be a bit trickier but
okay magnus of course knows what he's
doing we have e5
and now
white has a choice to make does he
advance with d5 and uh play very very
sharply and and go for something more
than a droid position or does he play
rook to e1 like he did in the game now
d5 is very double edged and i will just
show for example knight f6 we go after
the bishop rookie one we can defend now
black will grab a bit more space here
for example f5 attacks the rook rook
will go back and now after captures
captures maybe something like this
position would rise where white would
have the isolated the d-pawn which is
also a pass pawn uh and it's a trade-off
basically
but in the game rook to e1 was played
and this allows magnus to jump right
right into the game uh so he goes e
captures on d4 no longer allowing the
pawn to advance we have bishop captures
on d4 bishop captures queen characters
and now comes knight to f6 he offers a
queen trade and now we know that we are
going into the end game queen captures
on the e8 we have rook a capture 78 and
now bishop to f3 offering further trades
magnus happily trades rook capture sunny
one rook capture sunny one and uh here
magnus plays king to f8 and this is the
position that i enjoy the most from the
entire game
imagine you had a disposition you are
white here what do you play just you
know give it give it your best
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on uh trying to
play this game in a true spirit uh in
which the end game should be played and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is king to f1 i know some of
you guys wanted to play b4 right away
which is also fine but king to f1 is the
absolute best and we are going to
discuss why because it's very very
important it's basically the move that
shifts uh shifts the game in carson's
favor uh basically uh in the game uh
willems played rook to d1 now okay this
is a a bullet or a blitz or a bullet
blitz game so of course you don't have
time to
study the position if the situation was
otherwise i have no doubt that uh he
would have played the king to f1 but
after rook to d1 which was played in the
game there is a big problem here imagine
if king to f1 was played now of course
we are going into the end game you know
that the rook can be placed on d1 at any
time the bishop covers the d1 square so
we can either win the defile or force a
rook trade uh so king to f1 we want to
get our king
well as far into the the position as
possible and now uh the black king
cannot uh improve his position because
the rook controls the e file and this
would be uh a slight improvement but uh
a huge one uh
actually because now for example rook d2
white has no problems just rookie two
and if you trade okay we bring the king
closer in the game if you play rogue d1
check rookie one of course again you
offer a rook trade and here if you
finally trade uh king captures anyone
now magnus will play something like king
e7 and look at this the black king and
the white king both occupy the e file uh
which is good for both of them as they
wanna
of course you have to bring your king as
deep into the position as possible the
king in the end game is the most
powerful piece however after this king
to a f8 rook to d1 was played it seems
like
okay you're offering a rook trade and
then you're gonna start bringing your
king into the game but it's much much
different and remember that when we
ended that line that both the white king
and the black king occupied the e file
but here in the game magnus captures
very happily on d1 bishop captures on d1
and now okay magnus could go king e7
right away but he goes for knight to the
e4 first he wants to go for this knight
c3 attack the bishop and win the a2 pawn
so bishop to c2 attacking the knight now
knight c3 attacking the a2 pawn and now
a4 and now magnus plays king to e7 and
now
all of a sudden you can see that the
black king is on e7 and the white king
is on g1 so it okay it's white's move
king to f1 but uh both kings are not on
the e file so this is much much better
for black and uh of course this is a a
king and pawn end game with both players
having a minor piece white having the
bishop black having the knight uh one
tempo is is huge uh in such situations
so magnus goes king to d6 look at that
black king already on d6 and now white
has to make a choice does he allow king
to c5 or uh maybe he tries something
else so here probably best would be to
play something like f5 take away these
squares from the black king but still
the black king is coming into the
position king f2 king d4 and now after
king f3 we're going to play knight to a2
uh put a king on c3 kick away that
bishop and we're gonna start winning
material on the queen side so it's not
much better but okay b4 was played
taking away some very important squares
from carlson's king but now magnus just
plays c5 and here you can see that black
is really undermining that pawn
structure if you capture of course then
the black king just comes to b4 and
gobbles up everything
or if you play b5 as it was played in
the game now those pawns are
going to remain there on light squares
and
well it's a good thing that you can
defend them with your bishop it also
means that you will not be able to
move your bishop through them all that
much as you only have the light squares
so king e5 we have king to e1 now comes
king to d4 already you are attacking the
c4 pawn there should be three defending
now this is a very sad bishop it's so
it's almost like a pawn and now knight
to e4 now magnus is going to win this
pawn and there is nothing uh williams
can do about this we have f3 chasing
away the knight now comes knight to d6
and if you've seen the beginning of the
video that uh that i've shown them
actually playing and i will put both
links to both games in the
description below so you can check out
the entire games being played in real
time they were playing extremely fast
but here after magnus saw that he will
definitely win the pawn and that means
of course that he will win the game he
started playing very slowly and very
calmly he was almost like he he enjoyed
placing the pieces on every square so i
really suggest you watch the video uh so
here king 32 was played now magnus just
wins the pawn finally the white king
gets to the same file as the black king
but now uh it comes at the price of a
pawn so if you if you trade minor pieces
then of course the king and opponent
game is winning black is up a pawn so
here king e2 was played now comes knight
to d6 uh we have king back to d2 now
comes c4 bishop has to go back now comes
b6 we are now going to put all of our
pawns on dark squares and then we are
going to
exploit this weakness and then we're
going to go after these pawns it's uh
going to be impossible for white to
defend everything so here we have h4 h6
g5 uh sorry g4 g5 we have h captures and
g5h captures magnets making sure that
his pawns are of course on dark squares
bishop to h7 and now even f6
uh you don't have to play this but it
just shows that the white has absolutely
nothing to do here anymore so bishop to
g8 now comes c3 with check king to c2
and knight to c4 the knight is now
coming to d2 and you will have problems
defending the f3 pawn bishop to h7 was
played now comes knight to d2 and he was
in this position on move 41 that niels
williams resigned the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here uh the
problem is you will lose the f3 pawn and
even if you uh well uh for those of you
who are maybe new to chess who who want
to see how this might play out for
example bishop f5 we're going to win one
more pawn the one pawn the one extra
pawn was winning in this position two
extra pawns are just crushing and of
course nothing is stopping us from
winning these pawns as well so whatever
white plays as white really has nothing
to do all of the pawns are in dark
squares he has a light square bishop
there are no moves here let's say knight
h2 we go after the pawn white the white
can defend it now we go knight to f1
threaten uh this check to trade for
the knight for the bishop if bishop the
c8 trying to avoid this still knight to
e3 check king to c1 and now king to c4
king to b1 let's say now we're going to
play king to b4 and now we're going to
gobble up these pawns
of course the pawn and the knight are
stopping the white king from advancing
there is nothing white can do here uh so
really really an instructive game and it
really shows um
that uh well not only did the williams
play a a a great game but uh
what what it takes the you know uh just
having a great position and you can just
continue playing and you would enjoy the
game but this slight imprecision of
going rook to d1 right away instead of
first grabbing a tempo for yourself
would king to f1 as this would prevent
black from grabbing further tempe
uh that's uh that's uh basically what uh
what decided this game so yeah really uh
just a very very enjoyable uh in the in
the instructive end game where this came
to f1 just a beautiful move whereas rook
to d1 as you've seen allows magnus to
just you know uh get that king up the
board
too quickly for white to follow uh so
yeah that's uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it like i said check out
the links in the description below where
you can watch both of the games being
played in real time and uh yeah moral of
the of the story i guess would be to
never underestimate playing chess in a
bar as you never know when the world
champion might drop in
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
george elgin uh david kimura kevin
strange james the whip romano and
william manuel for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day